今日は
母の日ですこういう機会でもないと僕は
マミーに感謝の気持ちが伝えないのでせっかくの機会なんで
乾燥伝えようと思います僕は実は子供の頃
ずっと喘息持ちで
すごい常に喘息発作みたいな感じになってたんですけども
このお母さんはわざわざ遠くの
遠くの病院まで連れてってもらって薬とか治療をしてくれて今では
とても元気になりました
すごいまだ僕は小さい頃だったらうっすらしか覚えてないんですけどもすごい
頑張ったなという仕様てがあります
そんなこんなでもでも
お父さんお母さん家族の時で
22歳になり楽しく生活させていただいております本当にいつもありがとうございます
今はまあ一人グラスしてってこう母の日に直接言ってありがとうっていう感謝も伝える
だけでいいので売っても安いんですけどもういつも感謝してます
ごはん食べてるとか動画で馬鹿なことするんだとかいろんなことを2してくれてとても
僕は感謝しています
ありがとうございます僕は不器用なんで
直接感謝のことを表すのちょっと難しいので今日は
母への愛を込めて愛じゃないですねちょっとか間違えちゃいます
しかも4日彼への感謝を込めて
ちょっと僕なりの愛情表現ができたら相性表現じゃないですよ
今日は僕らしく
パサイの感謝を表してみようかと思います
というわけでうちはファイルのかあさんいつもありがとうということでちょっと自分
自分自分いっすねー
滑り台降りてみようと思いますまずを喋っ
がさんありがとう
この撮影するように子どもたちたくさんいたけど子どもたちが前回打って安全を確保し
た後とっているからにお母さん
周りを見る力を身につきました子どもたちにこんな危ない姿を見せちゃいけない
僕はそう思って10型の5時からずっとここで待ってました
今夜の8時です
3時間公園に行ったんですお母さんいつもありがとう言われてるわけねこれで
いただければお母さん
ばさんありがとこれからも元気でお父さんと仲良く
お母さんに気がすんだと言われるんだようそ東ない感じできました
思いますぞ
いきますよ
まじかこれマジかマジかマジらしい
マジックザギャザリングメッシュっお母さん
いつもありがとう
てきます
おかーさー
ハーイてああ
6安打を感と演奏ありがとうおかあさーん
おがーターン
ボカッ
ぜってー
おかしくとこしかなくたい
ああああああ
この良い本当に